لروسيا تؤكد دخول فايمر
قائد القوات المشتركه
توتر امني في شمال الضفه الغربيه غدا
اعتداءات من مستوطنين اسرائيليين على بلده
حواره
وسط مساعي من القاهره لاعاده العلاقات مع
سوريا وزير خارجيه مصريه يلتقي نظره
السوري في دمشق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نبدا النشره متطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
اعلنت
اعلن تقدم قوات
وقال مجموعه فاقنار تقاتل في وسط المدينه
مضيفا ان القوات الروسيه تسيطر على جميع
الطرق المؤديه اليها المتحدث استدرك
بالقول انه لا يزال من السابق لاوانه
الحديث عن تطويق المدينه
من الجانب الاوكراني تفقد قائد القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه العقيد الكسندر سيلسكي
الجبهه في مدينه
واعلنت قياده القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان
الزياره هدفك الى رفع الروح المعنويه
والتحدث عن الاستراتيجيه مع قاده الوحدات
التي تدافع عن المدينه المحاصره والقرى
المحيطه بها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعلنت حاله التاهب الجوي في العاصمه كييف
بعد سماع دوي في جارات في المدينه في
الوقت الذي يزداد الحديث عن تصعيد روسي
محتمل وفي ابرز تطورات اقال الرئيس
الاوكراني قائد القوات المشتركه
الاوكرانيه
في هذا المنصب في مارس الماضي زيانسكي لم
يقدم تفسيرا لاقاله لكن هذا القرار هو
الاحدث لسلسله طويله من التغييرات
القياديه الاخيره التي اجرتها ادارته
متصله بملفات فساد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك رائد وهل اقتربت معارك باخ
مدمن الحسم ام انها ما زالت تتراوح بين كر
وفر من الطرفين
صباح الخير احمد بالفعل المعارك ما زالت
مستعره هنا في الشرق الاوكراني خاصه في
مقاطعه التي تشهد يعني ضراوه في تلك
المعارك خاصه في محور مدينه التي ما زال
الجيش الروسي والقوات المواليه لروسيا
وقوات فاجنر عده فئات من المقاتلين يعني
يحاولون اقتحام هذه المدينه والسيطره
عليها يعني لا بد من الحديث ان تطويق
مدينه باخمد من قبل القوات الروسيه مستمر
منذ فتره زمنيه طويله ومحاوله اكمال الطوق
مستمره في اليومين الماضيين قوات فاغنر
التي تقاتل من الجهه الشماليه سيطرت على
عده بلدات بعد ان سيطرت على بريخوفكا ومن
ثم دوبنا وايضا اريهخفا وياجد
تستهدف الان مدينه مدينه
بغداد كمدينه بقدانه تقع في الناحيه
الغربيه الشماليه وهي اقرب الى الغرب وهذا
يعني ان التطويق يكاد يعني يكتمل يصلون
الى المناطق الغربيه اذا استطاعت القوات
الروسيه طبعا نعلم بان الناحيه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه مطوقه بالكامل لكن كانت مستعصيه
نوعا ما الناحيه الشماليه واكمل التطبيق
من الناحيه الشماليه ويوسعون الطوق غربا
وهذا لتضييق يعني الطريق الذي يؤدي الى
المرجعيه الغربيه حيث المراكز العسكريه
الكبرى الاوكرانيه بالفعل تتقدم القوات
الروسيه من الناحيه الجنوبيه الشرقيه ايضا
تقاتل داخل المدينه في معارك ضاريه الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا يدافع عن المدينه حتى الان
بشراسه لكن كيلومترات عديده بال اظهرت
فيديوهات
لقاده عسكريين يؤكدون ان 1700 متر فقط
تفصيلهم عن مركز مدينه باقمه الحديث عن
اقل من كيلومترين هنا لابد من الاشاره
احمد الى ان مدينه باغموت هي مدينه صغيره
كان يقطنها في السابق 70 الف نسمه والان
هي خاليه من السكان لكن الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لهذه المدينه التي تفتح
الباب امام الجيش الروسي للدخول الى المدن
الكبرى وهي الصافي
وكذلك قسطنطينوفكا الحديث عن الطريق
السريع الذي مازال يوصل الامدادات
العسكريه للجيش الاوكراني حتى الان طريق
الشاسوفيا مع باخموت تقول القياده
العسكريه لقوات باغنر بان هذا الطريق تحت
قصف المدفعيه الروسيه باستمرار ايضا هنا
اشاره لابد من ان نسلط الضوء عليها وهي ان
القوات الروسيه باتت تستخدم اسلحه متطوره
حديثه دخلت في اطار العم العسكريه ان كانت
المقاتلات وان كانت انواع قنابل تصل يعني
يصل وزن القنبله الى نصف طن 500 كيلو جرام
يعني تسقط من المقاتلات يعني ترميها
المقاتلات الروسيه على مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني
الوقت بعجاله نعتذر منكرون الانتقال لجهه
اخرى من دون اسكن معنا
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى متابعه
لكلمه لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه وسنعود
لمتابعه هذه الكلمه بعد قليل وهو يجتمع
فيها مع رؤساء الهيئات الاقليميه في روسيا
طبعا تاتي هذه الكلمه في ظل الحرب
المستعره بشده في شرق اوكرانيا خاصه في
منطقه باخ متلتي تحاصرها القوات الروسيه
كما قال
مراسله العربيه قبل والذي اكد ان اقل من
كيلومترين تفصل القوات الروسيه عن ضخمه
وهي تسيطر على هذه المدينه من اجي او
تحاصرها من الجهه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه الشماليه وتحاول سيطره السيطره
على الجهه الغربيه من هذه المدينه اذا
مشاهدينا نحن في انتظار متابعه كلمه
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الذي يجتمع مع رؤساء الهيئات الاقليميه في
روسيا
وقع رئيس الاوكراني على مجموعه جديده من
العقوبات الشخصيه التي
تستهدف77 روسيا واثنتين بل واثنين وتسعين
كيانا قانونيا حيث تضم قائمه افرادا يزعم
بطوارطهم في اختطاف اطفال اوكرانيين
بالاضافه الى جميع الذين يساعدون في دعم
المرتزق الذين يقاتلون ضد اوكرانيا كما
شملت العقوبات رياضيين روسا ممثلين اظهروا
دعما عاما للحرب
هذا وكشف تقرير امريكي صادر عن مركزيل
للابحاث ان روسيا تحتجز اكثر من سته الاف
طفل اوكراني فيما قد يرقى الى جريمه حرب
بحسب المركز التغيير واضاف ان احتجاز
الاطفال الاوكرانيين في روسيا يهدف الى
اعاده تثقيفهم وتشكيلهم وفق اهداف وغايه
موسكو مشيرا الى نقل اطفال لا تتجاوز
اعماره بل اعمار بعضهم اربعه اشهر الى 43
معسكر في انحاء روسيا من اجل التعليم
الوطني والتثقيف العسكري المتعلق بالجيش
الروسي
العربيه التقت الباحثه في المركز ان ثنيال
ريموند المدير التنفيذي لمختبر البحوث
الانسانيه بجامعه التي الذي توقع ان يكون
رقم الاطفال المخطوفين اكبر من المتوقع
حتى الان
لدينا عدد كبير من المواقع قيد البحث الان
نحن نحقق فيما يقرب من 43 موقعا ونشعر
بثقه كبيره بان عدد الاطفال المخطوفين
اعلى بشكل كبير بالاضافه لذلك نعتقد ان
الرقم 6000 الذي ذكرناه يضاف اليه 15,000
اعلنت الحكومه الاوكرانيه واعتقد ان الرقم
سيزداد في الايام والاسابيع المقبله
نعود مشاهدينا لمتابعه كلمه وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه الذي يجتمع مع رؤساء الهيئه
الاقليميه في روسيا
الموال
لتطوير بلدنا ولمضمان على مستوى المعيشه
لمواطنين ودمان الامن والاستقرار لروسيا
على الاتحاديه
لكثير من المعارضين بما في ذلك داخل روسيا
يقولون
اننا وضعنا الهدف لتشكيل وتاهيه الظروف
الملائمه لتطوير البلاد وما هي مقالات هذه
السياسه وهم لا يفهمون ما يجري حاليا
ومنذ فتره بسيطه كانت هناك
ظروف الخارجيه
اللازمه لتطويرنا كانت محدده من ليس من
قبل من قبل ما يسمى المليار الذهبي وهم
يدفعون جميع المبادرات على
الخارجيه الخاصه بهم لكي
يفرضوا القواعد الخاصه بهم على الجميع
الاستمرار في تنفيذ السياسه الاستعماريه
تسمح للغرب لمعايش حسب الاخرين
وسوف لا نعول على احد عندما
جرى الحديث عن تهيئه الظروف الخاصه بها
اللازمه بالنسبه لنا
واشدد على
ذلك
السياسه هي ليس متماثله مع سياسه العنانيه
الغربيه وهذه السياسه ستعكس التوافق بين
جميع الدول المستقله
وتتطابق مع مبادئ المتحده التي تم
انتهاكها مرارا وتكرارا من قبل الشركائنا
الغربي
[موسيقى]
امامنا عمل
وثيق ومكثف
ادعوكم انطلاق من هذا المفهوم واشكره
اشكركم على اشكر الموظفين لديكم
والمكاتب الاقليميه لوزاره تلعب دورا
متزايدا في هذه المرحله حيث
يهدف يهدف الشعبنا لتقديم المساعده
للمشاركين في العمليات العسكريه الخاصه
على الارض
اهتماما كبيرا لايجاد العلاقات والشركاء
سجاريه الوعيظه والمثمره وهذا سيكون من
السهل
في مناطق الاسيويه
واضعه ادعوهم الى الارتجال وابدعه في
لعملكم
ولقد تحدثنا في نوفمبر الماضيه
هذه المسائل
اجتماع رؤساء الاقليم الروسيه مع وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه وتم هناك اقرار على
تعليمات خاصه
باطلاقها عنان عن قدراتنا في العلاقات
الناتجاريه
سنناقش هذا الموضوع في الخريف المقبل
وتشاركون في تحضير في التحضير لهذه
المناسبه ونخططه خلالها ان نحدد
المتوفره لنا
ورسم الاتجاهات الرئيسيه لهذه
عامةً كبير للتعاون مع الدول الاعضاء في
الاقتصاد في الاتحاد الاقتصادي الاوراسي
وفروسيا هي شريك ناشط في حضريه المنظمه
تفهمون هذه المسائل وانتم
بشكل يومي
تحلون المسائل المتعلقه بهذا الموضوع
ننتظر منكم التعليمات
باشياء المشاركه العقليه بما في ذلك
اللجان الحكوميه
في
انشطتي حدك المنظمه
والكثير من رؤساء الاقاليم المشاركين في
هذه العمليه ولكن نرى افوق الاحتياط
في هذا الموضوع
من المطلوبا
تشاركوا على اقاليم الروسيه في عمل منظمه
بريكس وهناك مسارات
الهادفه لتعون الاقليمي
بهذا القدر وكنا معكم في متابعه لكلمه
وزير خارجيه
الذي يجتمع مع رؤساء الهيئات الاقليميه في
روسيا
من خلال هذه الكلمه وهجوما حدا على الغرب
قال انه فشل في فرض قواعده على النظام
العالمي وان الغرب مستمر في اتباع نهج
استعماري وقد فشل ايضا في تقسيم روسيا
وقال انه انتهك مواثيق الامم المتحده
مرارا وتكارا واكد ان روسيا تقيم علاقات
علاقات التعاون مثمره مع معظم دول العالم
في تعزيز علاقاتنا التجاريه الدوليه ايضا
مع دول العالم مشاهدينا نشاطنا مستمره
ونتابعها بعد هذا الفاصل
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد تشهد مناطق
شمال الضفه الغربيه ترابيا كبيرا حيث تم
حجده ثلاثه بل ثلاث كتائب عسكريه
اسرائيليه وذلك اعتداءات المستوطنين
الانتقامي على قريه حواره جنوب نابلس حيث
قتلوا فلسطينيا فيما اصيب نحو 100 وقام
نحو 400 مستوطن بحرق ثلاثين منزلا ومحل
تجاريا بشكل كامل واكثر من 40 بشكل جزئي
بعد عمليه حوار التي قتل فيها مستوطنان
هذا وقام الجيش الاسرائيلي بتجديد عمليات
التفتيش على الحواجز في محيط نابلس كما
دفع بكتيبتين اضافيتين الى شمال الضفه
وفيما دعت السلطه الفلسطينيه الى حمايه
دوليه للفلسطينيين ادانت الولايات المتحده
عمليه حواره واعتداءات المستوطنين التي
تلتها
هذا وتوعد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
في الضفه الغربيه والتي اسفرت عن مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين داعيا المستوطنين الغاضبين
الى عدم تطبيق القانون بايديهم بل
باياديهم على حد وصفه
كراه اليوم الصمغه وقعت كارثه مروعه اليوم
اود ان اتقدم بحر التعازي لعائله ينيف
التي فقدت اثنين من ابنائه الاعزاء لينتقم
الله لدمعهم يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي وقوات
الامن حاليا بمطارده القاتل سنجده ونقبض
عليه ونتعامل معه اطلب حتى عندما يكون
الدم فائرا والخواطر هائجه الا تطبق
القانون بايديكم يجب ان يقوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي وقوات الامن بعملهم واذكركم
بانهم قضوا في الاسابيع القليله الماضيه
على عشرات الارهابيين ومنع العشرات من
الهجمات الارهابيه دعوا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يكمل مطاردته لا تطبق القانون بايديكم
ومعا سنازم الارهاب
اعراب وفد الاتحاد الاوروبي الى اراضي
فلسطينيه عن انزعاجه من اعمال العنف التي
اندلعت بالقرب من حوار بضفه الغربيه
المحتله وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي في تغريده
على تويتر انه يجب على جميع الاطراف
التدخل بشكل سريع لوقف الاقتتال وحمايه
المدنيه مما يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ومنع سقوط المزيد من الضحايا
[تصفيق]
افادت وكاله الانباء السوريه باصول وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري الى دمشق
الزياره تاتي حسب مصادر العربيه في اطار
سعي القاهره لاعاده ترتيب العلاقات مع
سوريا واتخذت قرارا بتوسيع العلاقات معها
واشارت الى ان زياره وزير خارجيه مصر دمشق
اليوم تهدف لتنسيق التعاون في ملفات عده
وتحدثت المصادر عن ان القاهره سترسل وفودا
الى دمشق لتوسيع قاعده زياره بينهما
واضافت ان القاهره تحاول اقناعه واشنطن
بتخفيف العقوبات عن سوريا
طلبت منظمه صحه العالميه جمع
392 مليون دولار قبل مؤتمر الماني حين
تنظمه الامم المتحده وسويسرا والسويد في
جنيف لتجنب انهيار محتمل لقطاع الصحه في
اليمن وقالت المنظمه ان التمويل الجديد
مطلوب لضمان استمرار المرافق الصحيه في
تقديم الخدمات لنحو 13 مليون شخص من بينهم
50000 طفل دون سن الخامسه يعانون سوء
تغذيه حاده من مع خطا مباشر للوفاه
ونشير الى هذا الخبر عن وسائل الاعلام
الايطاليه تقول ان حصيله القتل ارتفعت
نتاج غرق مركبي للمهاجرين قرب سواحل
ايطاليا الى 60 قتيلا حتى الان
اعلنت بريطانيا مشاهدينا ان رئيس الوزراء
ريشيسون يلتقي اليوم الاثنين في لندن
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل للاعلان عن
تفاصيل التعديلات التي ادخلت على بروتوكول
ايرلندا الشماليه الخاص بخروج المملكه
المتحده من الاتحاد الاوروبي واكدت رئاسه
الوزراء البريطانيه في بيان انسونا
كوفونديلاين اتفقا على اتمام العمل
باللقاء شخصيا في لندن
يشهد جنوب اولئتك اليفورنيا الامريكيه
حاله مطريه غزيره تسببت في انجراف التربه
ادعو الاخر الى انهيارات اخرى نتابع
[موسيقى]
وفي الختام مشاهدينا العناوين
قوات المواليه لروسيات تؤكد دخول
قائد القوات المشتركه
توتر امني في شمال طفه الغربيه قد
تعتداءات
وسط مساع من القاهره لاعاده العلاقات مع
سوريا وزير خارجيه مصر يلتقي نظره السوري
في دمشق
نهايه نشر مشاهدينا كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]